mr. Dave Chester oh yes Manman how are
you good thank you welcome thank you
welcome to London 18.0 is just ended me
can you explain weather came from yes so
the the idea of doing an 18 point zero
or a pre-workout before the open stars
has been something has been floating in
my head for years I've always wanted to
do it we've never activated on it were
moved on it within crossfit we've never
made it a priority to execute on and
this year
Reebok asked me if I'd come out and do
this event with them and they said
they've reacted that idea they said
would you be open to doing a pre open
announcements and I said sure it's
called at 18.0 uh-huh and so we decided
to do it here and the workout had to be
true for CrossFit you know simple nice
by two movements that are common to the
open but with different twists yeah the
dumbbell snatch we put a new standard on
it just bringing it down below the head
before you make this switch and then
Burpee over the dumbbell is something
new we hadn't seen that yes it's pretty
cool because now you're gonna have
people assuming and they might be
assuming right or they might be assuming
wrong that that Burpee that we just
introduced will be the Burpee in the
open air well you'd like to throw a
couple of curveballs in right yeah and
so this is this is this 18.0 has
provided a nice little it's gonna get
people talking about what might be
coming this is just another day of test
drive Instagram post isn't here
basically which is for Reebok and live
and for this event this year um so yes
they're on Instagram I saw you trying to
put Dunn off during a photo shoot yeah
have the guys ever tried to put you off
during the games if they ever tried to
come up behind you and whisper just
random movements in your ear so that you
end up like to saying the wrong thing or
forgetting not during the games during
the games people they're pretty occupied
with what they have to do yeah that's
true
and they respect that I'm pretty
occupied with what I'm doing yes so
during the games no but
other events and another stuff like this
yeah guy the guys especially guys I'm
close with will will push me or poke at
me and do stuff but uh but typically not
at the games because everyone has their
own things going on yeah but maybe in
some of the open announcements or
something like that they might try and
they'll make little jokes but they're
also very nervous at that point - yeah
because they don't know what they're
about to do yep
and the open announcements are tough
because they have to announce to work
out and a few minutes later they have to
do it you got to go yeah so for sure
it's a demanding environment for them
for everyone yeah well especially for
those top athletes because of the fact
that like you know if you're not doing
an open and honest when you get a wife's
order then you get a process and you can
see what everyone else is doing and then
you get it you know I don't want to do
it tomorrow don't wanna go to Friday you
to do all you gotta set your own
schedule yeah if you're a part of the
open announcement you don't get to set
your own schedule but you don't have to
do it within five minutes after it's
announced especially last year with some
of the new movements that we saw yeah
some of the stuff like the dumbbell
cleans and then the racket lunges as
well and stuff like that and the
techniques that everyone developed you
get the guys that do the open
announcements they're the worst they get
no chance to prepare they're not totally
for work so like you didn't even look at
Matt Matt Scott when they did I guess it
was 18.3 the snatch squats not sure
squat snatch event Matt had the best
time in the world no no no he no men
ended up having the fastest time he beat
him at the last minute but Matt had the
second fastest time with no prep on his
first go yeah do you know if you repeat
them I don't think he did I'm pretty
sure he did not I think you know when
you've emptied the tank turning well I
don't think I hear it's not even empty
in the tank I don't think I think you're
going faster
it's more
he didn't need to do it have you done
enough you don't need to end yourself
already for next week he's looking at
the marathon he's looking at the
complete picture he doesn't want to win
just that event he went fooling the
whole thing for sure so he did enough
for him to be set up for successful for
the rest of the competition
I understand so Reebok and crossfit have
got a really strong partnership now
today's community I think has shown just
how cool that can be in the sort of
small events that you can do locally
that effect CrossFit is that on the
local level
yeah can you explain what the
partnership with Reeboks enabled you to
do that you might not have been able to
do without them has there been more
accesses what have you been able to do
with Reebok yeah the partnerships we've
raised they've exposed us to a new
community of people that traditionally
that we wouldn't par get or work with
just in the mass fitness community
outside of you know bringing media
bringing in people who aren't from your
traditional process grounds we actively
don't go out and try to promote
ourselves we let the brand promote
itself organically we let it grow by
word of mouth so this year it looks like
more than half a million people might do
be open hopefully full twenty or
something last year 420 thousand
something like that yeah how does it
feel knowing that your pen and paper is
going to influence the lives of so many
people like if you what you write on a
piece of paper is literally gonna define
someone's weekend yeah it's I don't
think about it like that too much but it
is like if I step back and think about
it that is pretty cool significant but I
think it I don't look at it that way I'm
thinking more about the
program fee that it's here's gonna be
about programming a test set it's gonna
rank the fittest in the world but also
be appropriate for 400 other thousands
got to be inclusive right yeah that
anyone can do it do you don't here's the
thing about the anyone can do it that
statement is true but it's also
misleading in the fact that anyone can
do it if you you need some experience
right like you need to have a loop you
need to know how to do some basic
process of mentorship even eat in the
scale do you still have to have some one
concept I would say not anybody can do
this scale division but a majority of
the world can you just have to have some
understanding of process yeah and the
movements to participate which isn't
asking a lot and which is it makes sense
yeah because if if if it was set up that
anyone can do it we just have you know a
walking competition yeah well you you'd
have to do movement that are so basic
that have no instruction yeah and
essentially all of our movements our
bodyweight movements anything with a
barbell there's some level of
instruction or some level of
technicality to them that you have to do
for sure so you've said do you test the
open workout yourself sometimes before
sending them to anybody else yes
do you ever find that you're fearing
them as you write them down or wanting
to back off the intensity seems you know
that you're about to punch yourself in
the face with it in about 30 minutes
well here's an idea I just like that I
fear not I don't mind doing them when
I'm creating them in that process but I
mind once scores have been established
and once people have done them because
now you see all
man a middle of a pocket yes this now I
have to do that or better uh-huh I get
the anxiety from them when I have to
actually do them and I know other
people's school you got to watch that
school go up so when I do then in
prepping for then before anyone's ever
done him I'm not too worried about it
because I know it's like I'll get it
another one in the world right now if we
don't work out I'll get a sense of how
it feels and how the mood would feel and
overall that it hurts but but then when
I do them because I'll test them and
then during the open week I'll do them
officially so like I don't use my scores
from when I attach today I make it
official and I do it within the window
with the judge and go through the whole
process I understand and that's when I
fear them but in the creation and you
know some of them like I don't like
movements like Bruster's and the things
people think they don't like so when
they have those in there too I'm not
excited about testing yeah VESA so new
none away it's been released this week
what is your favorite pair of Reebok
shoes from over the years have you got a
favorite pair that sticks out I never
really think of my shoes I just move and
I like I just I'm good I mean it's kind
of how I've been brought up they just
you want to be prepared for whatever you
have that's a sale yeah whatever you're
gonna work with whatever you're gonna
use you make it happen
so the say I feel the same way about
barbells a barbell is a little different
I'll grab that yeah of course you want a
nice one but if you don't have a nice
movie you can make it work for sure yeah
but I do like these they feel great and
I thought the sevens were great I think
these are great yeah
a little bit more of a hill drop in
these I noticed which feels good yeah
really really good
what's the coolest group chapter you're
in cool this group chat yeah on iMessage
or like what's up or whatever have you
got some cool group shots they're doing
no I have some business text groups that
I named some of my core team and those
I don't really they're just not me okay
I got it I'm so I wouldn't like to guess
how many gyms you've been to around the
world I don't know anymore but I've been
doing an awful lot yeah have you got a
top three coolest gyms yes there's need
to come to mind there's some gyms in
China that were really cool that I just
remember that we're very unique and
partly because they were in China and
you and expect to find such nice
CrossFit gyms I mean I didn't you know
you can't once I was there now it makes
sense but before I went I went a couple
years ago I had no idea that I'd find
some of the nicest CrossFit gyms in the
world in China such an emerging market
yeah exactly so that was that was unique
yeah I don't have a favorite CrossFit
gym I think I like somebody they all
have such different flavors and such
different looks such different
experiences that yeah in a different way
but also the exact same training
methodology that it arrives in in a
culturally different way right yeah
totally um
you're in The Hunger Games and there's
only other Games athletes there who's
gonna be the hardest to kill I don't
even know what the Hunger Games are you
know that battle royale you've got to
like every W at kind of kind of okay WWF
who's gonna be the hardest to get out of
the rain do you think of all the games
are fleets from this year from this year
out of all the games athletes they think
about that well I think Matt's pretty
here's what I respect about Matt and
Michael is because he's really a fighter
and what I mean I don't mean a physical
fighter but I mean mental fighter is
like he really wants to win no matter
what it takes and in years past you can
ask me to even I so here's something
that I'm just competing against myself
and I you know I want to do it as best
as I can but the reality is when you get
out there you have to compete against
those to your left and right and you
have to do better than even what the
best you can is
that is if you want to win and Matt
understands that and when you watch Matt
and rich Froning had that to plunder of
a son when you watch those two they're
not trying to do the best they can
they're trying to beat the guy to the
left and right of him absolutely and
sometimes that doesn't even mean they
have to be the best that they can and
means they could be 70% of what they are
and they're still beating the guys
that's that's what makes a good
competitor right as opposed to just a
good athlete so that type of mentality
also would make the type of person I
wouldn't want to fight in a cage or I
wouldn't want to be within a scenario
like that because they they want to win
at all cost and that's that's a powerful
thing and it's it's powerful thank you
Dave I appreciate your time thank you
very much
[Music]
you